عوده الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث دخل
الدعم العسكري الغربي لكيف مستويات
النوعيه غير مسبوقه من الدبابات والاسلحه
الثقيله المتطوره فقد اورد التقارير
اعلاميه غربيه ان بريطانيا تخطط لارسال
دبابات من طراز شالنجر اثنين الى اوكرانيا
لمساعدتها في التصدي للهجمات الروسيه
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه اكدت ان لندن
قدمت اوكرانيا حتى الان اكثر من 200 مركبه
مدرعه من بينها انظمه دفاع جوي من طراز
ستورمر والاسبوع الماضي اعلانات الحكومه
الالمانيه اناسه تسلم اوكرانيا 40 ناقله
جند مدرعه من طراز مارتن بينما تلحوا كيف
في تزويدها الدباباتها لا بيرد اثنان
المتطوره لكن الامر ما زال قيد النقاش في
برلين وقررت الولايات المتحده تزويده
اوكرانيا بمدرعاته برادلي وناقلات جند
المدرعه ادفعها ذاتيه الدفع وصواريخ هاي
مارس الدقيقه وصواريخ سيسبارو المضاده
للطائرات اما فرنسا فكانت اول دوله غربيه
توافق على تسليم اوكرانيا دبابات خفيفه من
طراز اي ام اكس 10 ار سي وهي مركباته قتال
مدرعه بدا تصنيعها في ثمانينيات القرن
الماضي ومزوده بمدفع من عيار 150 م
مقابل الاسلحه الموعوده كانت اوكرانيا قد
تسلمت بالفعل اسلحه النوعيه مختلفه اسهمت
في اعاده توجيه مسار المعارك لصالح كيف
ومن ابرزها منظومه هاي مارس الامريكيه
التي تسلمتها اوكرانيا في يونيو الماضي
وهي راجمات الصواريخ دقيقه التوجيه تحمل
واحده منها سته صواريخ كما حصلت اوكرانيا
في مارس الماضي على صواريخ ستينجر
الامريكيه المضاده للطائرات وهي صواريخ
محموله على الكتف وتفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت
كما زودت الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا في
نهايه فبراير الماضي بمدافع حول ذاتي
اعيره مختلفه تطلق تطلق قذائف دقيقه
التوجيه على اهدافها اما اول الاسلحه
النوعيه لاوكرانيا فكانت صواريخ الامريكيه
المضادات
وقد بدات تسليمها قبل الحرب وتحديدا في
ديسمبر عام 2001 2020